yeah really interesting you mentioned
the commonwealth because of course jason
donovan from australia you haven't lived
there for a while though you were saying
to me
um no but i'm still in australia still
proud
um you are performing tonight what
exactly are you doing um i'm part of
lloyd webber's uh theater moment i
suppose and joseph yeah so i'm excited
about that how's the rehearsal's been
going because people haven't had that
long have they out there on those stages
well i've had 30 years of rehearsing
this moment in a way but but um
but no it's you know it is
you know we've got something special to
finish the moment so
i'm hoping that that all goes to plan
and look it's just awesome to be here
and
i mean what an event you know you work a
lifetime for something like this and
i guess it's sort of hard to take it all
in really and i hope the weather is good
for us tonight which it seems to be so
yeah fingers crossed that weather
forecast has kind of changed over the
last few years but so far so good so far
so good when you got the call what did
you think kind of that you're being
invited it's a really unique moment
isn't it oh yeah it is i got a i got a
voice mail message from andrew saying i
need to speak to you about something
urgently and i called him back and he
said would you be part of it and i said
i said sure you know
[Music]
i mean again you know it's such a
momentous occasion
and
you know as an australian i guess i
understand what um
what the commonwealth means to you know
uh the queen and and to us and to
england and this moment i don't think
we're ever going to see a moment like
this well we're not going to see a
moment like this in our lifetimes again
so
um
you know to pay respect to her
um and
to celebrate you know through music
music is magic you know it it brings
back
memories and it makes you feel good so
that's what we plan to do in
a minute or two you know
she isn't going to be here but i think
for her she obviously wants to make sure
this is a celebration for everyone after
what's been a tough couple of years
hasn't it people haven't been able to
perform in public and people haven't
been able to to get together yeah the
crowds on the mail are just london
london is buzzing yeah yeah yeah it's um
look i mean you know it is it's very
exciting i mean i've been anxious but
you know i think that's okay as well too
so you know i'm excited to perform and
growing up were jubilees were these kind
of milestones for the queen something
that you and your your family would
celebrate and mark over in australia
sure i mean we deal with it very
differently than you do um you know
because of distance um but you know i've
always been
you know
you know i've always valued um
the royal family and what it's brought
to our country and i guess the stability
and the respect that it has
not just in australia but throughout the
commonwealth so
so you know where where it goes from now
is not in my hands it's in in the future
generations of australians but um but
for me personally um to represent my
country here today is awesome and
celebrate the queen incredible isn't it
70 years 96 years old still going strong
hopefully
at home yeah she's cool yeah i mean you
know beyond
the bar's high
i know how do you surpass her you can't
possibly at all good luck this evening
you haven't had that much rehearsal time
but um i'm sure it would be amazing to
be incredible so there you go jason
donovan yeah one of another the stars
who's uh going to be on those four
different stages in front of buckingham
palace later on tonight